البيت من استطاع اليه سبيلا
ومن كفر فان الله غني عن العالمين
قل يا اهل الكتاب لم تكفرون بايات الله
والله شهيد على ما تعملون
قل يا اهل الكتاب لم تصدون عن سبيل لله من
امن تبغونها عوجا
تبغونها عوجا وانتم شهداء
وما الله بغافل عما تعملون
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تطيعوا فريقا من
الذين اوتوا الكتاب يردوكم
يردوكم
بعد ايمانكم كافرين
وكيف تكفرون وانتم تتلى عليكم ايات الله
وفيكم رسوله
ومن يعتصم بالله فقد هدي الى صراط مستقيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
طيبا مباركا في من السماوات ومن الارض
ومنا ما بينهما ومش
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون
واعتصموا بحبل الله جميعا ولا تفرقوا
واذكروا نعمه الله عليكم اذ كنتم اعداء
فالف بين قلوبكم
فالف بين قلوبكم فاصبحتم
بنعمته
اخوانا
وكنتم على شفا حفره من النار فانقذكم
منها
كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته لعلكم تهتدون
ولتكن منكم امه يدعون الى الخير ويامرون
بالمعروف وينهون عن المنكر
واولئك
هم المفلحون
ولا تكونوا كال الذين تفرقوا واختلفوا من
بعد ما جاءهم
البينات
واولئك
لهم عظ واولئك
لهم عذاب عظيم
يوم تبيض وجوه وتسود وجوه
فاما الذين اسودت وجوههم
اكفرتم
بعد ايمانكم
فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم تكفرون
واما الذين ابيضت وجوههم ففي رحمه الله
هم فيها خالدون
تلك ايات الله نتلوها عليك بالحق
وما الله يريد ظلما للعالمين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
كده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
بسم الله
[Arabic recitation]
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
خير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبرلام
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
على قدير
அலாம்
க
‏first
wasপ
andஹ
of 105000
first timeered
100000 mar you
‏CR for that
so anybody who did not get a chance to
participate in that and maybe not the
jum pray if you want to you know you can
contribute to that more because our
expenses for the year we have estimated
that to be 300,000
so that's a run rate of 25,000 a month
that includes
the the payroll that includes the u
which are signicant by the way brothers
and sister
அசிவாசிவா
பஜே
মা
அக
anybody want toching
up somebody000
at least we can do this000
without name
‏backy
الله
الله اكبر
تكبير000
‏asendites
are you 25000ites
our
here ify
اللهing
as you sister
you enment to 100 stud now and
prov
‏com
me
per some
upay
pleas
make
அo
6:30டு 8 ஓகே
7m 6:30 ஓகே 6:30
So this was the inarification I have
said
‏serv
on
that not there serv
also satday also and that is 6 to the
paring lot vant until our is pray is
complete so about 9 o so tomorrow you
cann par in the next neb paring we have
by the way cleared more
‏are here so
more cars now so keep looking for more
opportun
paring so there is ample paring you just
have to go little
the secity yes they are they are there
to guide you so please follow their
requirement so tomorrow you will not be
able to park in the church parking for
‏now
so i think we have announced এড
was missing something we are looking for
some sch teachers some interest
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول ل
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
ان شاء الله تعالى
second
ال عمران
سهء
سوره الران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
جزاكم الله
سوره البقره سوره ال عمران
اللهved
[Silence]
‏timeر
سه الران
‏another
بالقول والسان
وجهاد بالسيف والسنان
جهاد
with evidence
‏mindsical
and
props and messengers and their followers
now if we were to upage
a very long chapter
احد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏So this is what
120 of the entiry of the military the
army. 40 men out of over a000 he gave
them a command he said stay on this
mountain stay on this mount protect our
rear do not come down from here until I
myself come and get you.
‏giant birdsoping
down from the heavens anding up into the
sky do not come down from this mountain
come take you could be more clear
منكم يريد ومنكم من يريد الاخره
‏They figured oh the battle over we
already won now just booty the spoils of
look at that sword look at that piece of
armor I need to get that before someone
else gets to it
that whisper that drive that's in your
heart and my heart and the back of your
mind and mine. And so what happened?
They came down. ‏If you with one of them
and listen to their arent why they came
down from there would be very compelling
arent
from their point the ble over
and what happen our prop
was almost killed
he was beat in his head
helet on until it bent itself into his
face
‏broke his froth was broken in that
bleed broken for the rest of his life he
was nearly killed
not to mention over nine other men of
the greatest of men were killed
defending himall
what the message here
here is the lesson very quickly listen
to thison because it applies to
‏are
all the east
are oppressed do we have on them
when we come down from our proverbial mo
our mountain that we are supposed to be
on of obedience does it aff ours across
the water yes it does
their loss is our los
and ‏areysically
among us محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
ifysically with us but is not we will
even with us
and if is not
uph by us ‏and he is spiritually with us
in the sense that we uphold his
commandments we follow his sunah then we
will win even while he in grave over in
that's theage that's the enal
that we could up in
that is
if you
[Silence]
بحانه وى
صلاه ان شاء الله
تراويح والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وجزاكم الله خيرا
[Silence]
نستعين الصراط المستقيم
سمع
يا
[Silence]
بسم الله
الصراط المستقيم
سمع الله لمن حمده ربنا
[Silence]
استووادلوا
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج ولا
تختلفوا فتختلف قلوبكم ‏Please
double check your makeent
and double check your kids make
to take them to the babysitter
right take them to the babysitter take
home and put in bed but this is not a
playground thank
الله اكبر سبحانك
وتبارك
اله خير
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولله ل ما في السماوات وما في الارض والى
الله ترجع الامور
كنتم خير امه اخرجت للناس تامرون بالمعروف
وتنهون عن المنكر وتؤمنون بالله
ولو امن اهل الكتاب لكان خيرا لهم منهم
المؤمنون واكثرهم هم الفاسقون
لن يضروكم الا اذى وان يقاتلوكم يولوكم
الادبار ثم لا ينصرون
ضربت عليهم الذله اينما ثقفوا الا بحبل من
الله وحبل من الناس
الا بحبل من الله وحبل من الناس وباءوا
بغضب من الله
وضربت عليهم المسكنه
ذلك بانهم كانوا يكفرون بايات الله
ويقتلون
الانبياء
بغير حق ذلك بما عصوا وكانوا يعتدون
ليسوا سواء
من اهل الكتاب امه قائمه
يتلون ايات الله اناء الليل وهم يسجدون
يؤمنون بالله واليوم الاخر ويامرون
بالمعروف وينهون عن المنكر
ويسارعون في الخيرات
واول اولئك
من الصالحين
وما يفعلوا من خير فلن يكفروه
والله عليم بالمتقين
ان الذين كفروا لن تغني عنهم اموالهم ولا
اولادهم من الله شيئا
واولئك
اصحاب
النار هم فيها خالدون
مثل ما ينفقون في هذه الحياه الدنيا كمثل
ريح فيها صر اصابت
اصابت حرث قوم ظلموا انفسهم فاهلكته
وما ظلمهم الله ولكن انفسهم يظلمون
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا بطانه من
دونكم
لا يالونكم خبالا ودوا ما عندتم قد بدت
البغضاء
من افواههم وما تخفي صدورهم اكبر قد بينا
لكم الايات لعلكم تعقلون
قد بينا لكم الايات ان كنتم تعقلون
ها انتم اول تحبونهم
ولا يحبونكم
وتؤمنون بالكتاب
واذا لقوكم قالوا امنا
واذا خلوا عضوا عليكم الانامل من الغيب
قل موتوا بغيظكم ان الله عليم
ب ان الله ان الله عليم بذات الصدور
ان تمسسكم حسنه تسؤهم
وان تصبكم سيئه يفرحوا بها
وان تصبروا وتتقوا لا يضر ركم كيدهم شيئا
ان الله بما يعملون محيط
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واذ غد دوت من اهلك تبوء المؤمنين مقاعد
للقتال والله سميع عليم
اذ هم الطائفتان
منكم ان تفشلا والله وليهما
وعلى الله فليتوكل
المؤمنون
ولقد نصركم الله ببدر وانتم
اذله فاتقوا الله
فاتقوا الله لعلكم تشكرون
اذ تقول للمؤمنين
الن يكفيكم ان يمدكم ربكم بثلاثه الاف من
الملائكه
بثلاثه الاف من الملا ملائكه
منزلين
بلى ان تصبروا وتتقوا وياتوكم من فورهم
هذا
يمددكم ربكم بخمسه الاف من الملائكه
مسومين
وما جعله الله الا بشرى لكم ولتطمئن
قلوبكم
به وما النصر الا من عند الله العزيز
الحكيم
ليقطع طرفا من الذين كفروا او يكبتهم
فينقلبوا
خائبين
ليس لك من الامر شيء او يتوب عليهم او
يعذبهم فانهم ظالمون
ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض يغفر
لمن يشاء
ويعذب من يشاء
والله غفور رحيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تاكلوا الربا
اضعافا مضاعفه
واتقوا الله لعلكم تفلحون
واتقوا النار التي اعدت للكافرين
واطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون
وسارعوا الى مغفره من ربكم وجنه عرضها
السماوات والارض اعدت للمتقين
الذين ينفق قون في السراء
والضراء
والكاظمين الغيظ والعافين عن الناس والله
يحب المحسنين
والذين اذا فعلوا فاحشه او ظلموا انفسهم
ذكروا الله
فاستغفروا لذنوبهم ومن يغفر الذنوب
الا الله
ولم يصروا على ما فعلوا وهم يعلمون
اولئك
جزاؤهم
مغفره
مغفره من ربهم وجنات
وجنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
خالدين فيها ونعم اجر العاملين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
لوست
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
قد خلت من قبلكم سنن فسيروا في الارض
فانظروا كيف كان عاقل قبه المكذبين
هذا بيان للناس وهدى وموعظه
هذا بيان للناس وهدى وموعظه للمتقين
ولا تهنوا ولا تحزنوا وانتم الاعلون ان
كنتم مؤمنين
ان يمسسكم قرح لقد مس القوم قرح مثله وتلك
الايام نداولها بين الناس
وليعلم الله الذين امنوا ويتخذ منكم شهداء
والله لا يحب الظالمين
وليمحص الله الذين امنوا ويمحق الكافرين
ام حسبتم ان تدخلوا الجنه
ولما يعلم الله الذين جاهدوا منكم
ولما يعلم الله الذين جاهدوا منكم ويعلم
الصابرين
ولقد كنتم تمنون
الموت من قبل ان تلقوه
فقد رايتموه وانتم تنظرون
وما محمد الا رسول قد خلت من قبله الرسل
افان مات او قتل انقلبتم على اعقابكم
ومن ينقلب على عقبيه فلن يضر الله شيئا
وسيجزي الله الشاكرين
وما كان لنفس ان تموت الا باذن الله كتابا
مؤجلا
ومن يرد ثواب الدنيا نؤته منها ومن يرد
ومن يرد ثواب الاخره نؤته منها وسنجزي
الشاكرين
وكاي من نبي قاتل معه ربيون كثير
فما وهنوا لما اصابهم في سبيل الله وما
ضعفوا وما استكانوا
والله يحب الصابرين
وما كان قولهم الا
قالوا ربنا اغفر لنا ذنوبنا
ربنا اغفر لنا ذنوبنا واسرافنا في امرنا
وثبت اقدامنا وانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
فاتاهم الله ثواب الدنيا وحسن ثواب الاخره
الله يحب المحسنين.
يا ايها الذين امنوا لئن تطيعوا فريقا من
الذين كفروا
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تطيعوا فريقا من
الذين كفروا يردوكم
يردوكم على اعقابكم فتنقلبوا
خاسرين
بل الله مولاكم وهو خير الناصرين
سنلقي في قلوب الذين كفروا الراب اشركوا
بالله ما لم ينزل به سلطانا
وماواهم
النار
النار وبئس مثوى الظالمين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال الين
امين
ولقد صدقكم الله وعده اذ تحسونهم
باذنه حتى اذا فشلتم في الامر حتى اذا
فشلتم وتنازعتم في الامر وعصيتم
وعصيتم من بعد ما اراكم
ما تحبون
منكم من يريد الدنيا ومنكم من يريد الاخره
ثم صرفكم عنهم ليبتليكم ولقد عفى عنكم
والله ذو فضل على المؤمنين
اذ تصعدون ولا تلوون على احد والرسول رسول
يدعوكم في اخراكم
فاثابكم غما بغ
تحزنوا على ما فاتكم ولا ما اصابكم
والله خبير بما تعملون
ثم انزل عليكم من بعد الغم امنه نعاساه
امنه
نعاس يغشى طائفه
منكم
وطائفه
قد اهمتهم
انفسهم يظنون
يظنون بالله غير الحق ظن الجاهليه يقولون
يقولون هل لنا من الامر من شيء قل ان
الامر كله لله
يخفون في انفسهم
ما لا يبدون لك يقولون لو كان لنا من
الامر شيء ما قتلنا هاه
قل لو كنتم في بيوتكم لبرز الذين كتب
عليهم القتل الى مضاجعهم
وليبتدي الله ما في صدور والله عليم بما
يكتبون
وليبتلي الله ما في صدوركم وليمحص ما في
قلوبكم
والله عليم بذات الصدور
ان الذين تولوا منكم او التقى الجمعان
انما استزلهم الشيطان ببعض ما كسبوا
ولقد عفى الله عنهم ان الله غفور حليم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تكونوا كالذين
كفروا وقالوا لاخوانهم
وقالوا لاخوانهم اذا ضربوا في الارض او
كانوا غزا لو كانوا عندنا ما ماتوا
لو كانوا عندنا
ما ماتوا وما قتلوا
ليجعل الله ذلك حسره
في قلوبهم
والله يحيي ويميت والله بما تعملون بصير
ولئن قتلتم في سبيل الله او متم لمغفره من
الله ورحمه
لمغفره من الله ورحمه خير مما يجمعون
ولئن متم او قتلتم لى تحشرون
فبلا رحمه من الله لنت
ولو كنت فضا غليظ القلب لانفضوا من حولك
فاعف عنهم واستغفر لهم وشاورهم في الامر
فاذا عزمت فتوكل على الله
ان الله يحب المتوكلين
ان ينصركم الله فلا غالب
وان يخذلكم فمن ذا الذي ينصركم
من بعده وعلى الله فليتوكل
المؤمنون
وما كان لنبي ان يغل ومن يغلل يات بما ظل
يوم القيامه
ثم توفى كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا يظلمون
افمن اتبع افمن اتبع رضوان الله كمن باء
بسخط من الله
وماواه جهنم وبئس المصير
هم درجات عند الله
والله بصير بما يعملون
لقد من الله على المؤمنين اذ بعث فيهم
رسولا منهم يتلوا عليهم اياته
يتلوا عليهم اياته ويزكيهم ويعلمهم
الكتاب والحكمه
وان كانوا من قبل لفي ضلال مبين
او
لقد من الله على المؤمنين اذ اذ بعث فيهم
رسولا من انفسهم
يتلوا عليهم الكتاب
يتلوا عليهم الكتاب والحكمه ويزكي
ويزكيهم ويعلمهم الكتاب والحكمه
وان كانوا من قبل لفي ضلال مبين
اولما اصابتكم مصيبه قد عصبتم مثليها قلتم
انا هذا
قل هو من عند انفسكم
ان الله على كل شيء قدير
وما اصابكم يوم التقى الجمعان فباذن الله
وليعلم المؤمنين
وليعلم الذين نافقوا وقيل قيل لهم تعالوا
قاتلوا في سبيل الله او ادفعوه
قالوا لو نعلم قتالا لاتبعناكم
هم للكفر يومئذ اقرب منهم للايمان
يقولون بافواههم
ما ليس في قلوبهم
والله اعلم بما يكتمون
الذين ق يا الذين قالوا لاخوانهم وقعدوا
لو كانوا عندنا
لو كانوا لو اطاعونا ما قتلوه
قل فادراؤوا عن انفسكم
الموت ان كنتم
صادقين
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
[Silence]
صح
‏you
to your
mind make it up some do
‏bending a little bitches
[Silence]
okay insall we will continue here in
about a minut will say one more
‏allyed
nice bear at home laying down going to
sleep
‏is place
in thinking about
timeace
جزاكم الله
ابو عامر احمد جابر ان شاء
شف
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل استو
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولا تحسب ان الذين قتلوا في سبيل الله
امواتا بل احياء
بل احياء
عند ربهم يرزقون
فرحين بما اتاهم الله من فضله ويستبشرون
بالذين لم يلحقوا بهم من خلفهم
الا خوف عليهم ولا هم يحزنون
يستبشرون بنعمه من الله وفضل وان الله لا
يضيع اجر المؤمنين
الذين استجابوا لله والرسول من بعد ما
اصابهم القرح للذين احسنوا منهم واتقوا
اجر عظيم
الذين قال لهم الناس ان الناس قد جمعوا
لكم فاخشوهم
فزادهم ايمانا وقالوا حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل
فانقلبوا بنعمه من الله وفضل لم يمسسهم
سوء
واتبعوا رضوان الله والله ذو فضل عظيم
انما ذلكم الشيطان يخوف اولياءه
فلا تخافوهم وخافون
فلا تخافوهم وخافون ان كنتم مؤمنين
ولا يحزنك الذين يسارعون في الكفر انهم لن
يضر الله شيئا
يريد الله الا يجعل لهم حظا في الاخره
ولهم عذاب عظيم
ان الذين اشتروا الكفر بالايمان لن يضروا
الله شيئا
ولهم عذا عذاب اليم
ولا تحسبن الذين كفروا انما نملي لهم خير
لانفسهم
انما نملي لهم ليزدادوا اثما ولهم عذاب
مهين
ما كان الله ليذر المؤمنين على ما انتم
عليه حتى يميز الخبيث من الطيب
وما كان الله ليطلعكم على الغيب ولكن الله
يجتبي من رسله من يشاء
فامنوا بالله ورسله وان تؤمنوا وتتقوا
فلكم اجر عظيم
ولا يحسبن الذين يفرحون بما اتاهم الله
ولا يحسبن الذين يبخلون بما اتاهم الله من
فضله هو خيرا لهم بل هو شر لهم
سيطوق ما بخلوا به يوم القيامه
ولله ميراث السماوات والارض والله خبير
بما تعملون
والله بما تعملون خبير
لقد سمع الله قول الذين قالوا ان الله
فقير ونحن اغنياء
سنكتب ما قالوا وقتلهم الانبياء
بغير حق ونقول ذوقوا عذاب الحريق
ق
ذلك بما قدمت ايديكم وان الله ليس بظلام
للعبيد
الذين قالوا ان الله عهد الينا الا نؤمن
لرسول حتى ياتينا بقربان
حتى ياتينا بقربان تاكله النار
قل قد جاءكم
رسل من قبلي بالبينات وبالذي قلتم فلم
قتلتموهم
ان كنتم صادقين
فان كذبوك فقد كذب رسل من قبلك
جاؤوا بالبينات والزبر والكتاب المنير
كل نفس ذائقه
الموت
وانما
توثون اجوركم يوم القيامه
فمن زحزح عن النار وادخل الجنه فقد فاز
وما الحياه الدنيا
الا متاع الغرور
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضال ضالين
امين
لتبلون
في اموالكم وانفسكم
ولتسمعن
من الذين اوتوا الكتاب من قبلكم ومن الذين
اشركوا اذ كثيرا
وان تصبروا وتتقوا فان ذلك من عزم الامور
واذ اخذ الله ميثاق الذين اوتوا الكتاب
لتبيننه
للناس ولا تكتمونه
فنبذوه وراء
ظهورهم واشتروا به ثمنا قليلا
فبئس ما يشترون
لا تحسبن
الذين يبخلون
الذين يحبون اي ولا يحسبن
الذين يفرحون بما اتوا ويحبون ان يحمدوه
لا تحسبن الذين يفرحون بما اتوا ويحبون ان
يحمدوا بما لم يفعلوه
فلا تحسبنهم
بمفازه من العذاب
ولهم عذاب اليم
ولله ملك السماوات والارض والله على كل
شيء قدير
ان في خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف الليل
والنهار لايات
لايات لاولي الالباب
الذين يذكرون الله قياما وقعودا وعلى
جنوبهم
ويتفكرون في خلق السماوات والارض ربنا ما
خلقت هذا باطلا
سبحانك
سبحانك فقنا عذاب النار
ربنا انك من تدخل النار فقد اخزيته
وما للظالمين من انصار
ربنا اننا سمعنا مناديا ينادي للايمان ان
امنوا بربكم فامنا
ربنا فاغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الابرار
ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا
يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد
فاستجاب لهم ربهم اني لا اضيع عمل عامل
منكم من ذكر او انثى
من ذكر او انثى بعضكم من بعض فالذين
هاجروا واخرجوا من ديارهم واوذوا في سبيلي
وقاتلوا وقتلوا
وقاتلوا وقتلوا لاكفرن
عنهم سيئاتهم ولادخلنهم
ولادخلنهم
جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار
ثوابا من عند الله والله عنده حسن الثواب
لا يغرنك
تقلب الذين كفروا في البلاد
متاع قليل ثم ماواهم جهنم وبئس المهاد
لكن الذين اتقوا ربهم لهم جنات
لهم جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
خالدين فيها نزلا من عند الله
وما عند الله خير للابرار
وان من اهل الكتاب لمن يؤمن بما انزل
اليكم وما انزل اليهم
وم وان وان
من اهل الكتاب من يؤمن بالله وما انزل
اليكم وما انزل اليهم خاشعين لله
خاشعين لله لا يشترون بايات ل ثمنا قليلا
اولئك
لهم اولئك
لهم اجرهم عند ربهم
والله سريع الحسابه
يا ايها الذين امنوا اصبروا وصابروا
ورابطوا واتقوا الله
واتقوا الله لعلكم تفلحون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط
الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون
به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
واتوا اليتامى اموالهم ولا تتبدلوا الخبيث
بالطيب ولا تاكلوا اموالهم الى اموالكم
انه كان حوبا كبيرا وان خفتم الا تقسطوا
في اليتامى فانكحوا ما طاب لكم من النساء
مثنى وثلاث ورباع
فان خفتم الا تعدلوا فواحده او ما ملكت
ايمانكم
ذلك ادنى الا تعولوا
واتوا النساء ء صدقاتهن
نحله فان طبن لكم عن شيء منه نفسا فكلوه
هنيئا مريئا
ولا تؤتوا السفهاء
اموالكم التي جعل الله لكم قياما وارزقوهم
فيها واكسوهم وقولوا لهم قولا معروفا فا
وابتلوا اليتامى حتى اذا بلغوا النكاح فان
انستم منهم رشدا فادفعوا اليهم اموالهم
ولا تاكلوها اسرافا وبدارا ان يكبروا ومن
كان غنيا فليستعفف ومن كان فقيرا فلياكل
بالمعروف
فاذا دفعتم اليهم اموالهم فاشهدوا عليهم
وكفى بالله حسيبا
للرجال نصيب مما ترك الوالدان والاقربون
وللنساء
نصيب مما ترك الوالدان والاقربون مما قل
منه كثر نصيبا مفروضا
واذا حضر القسمه اولو القربى واليتامى
والمساكين فارزقوهم منه وقولوا لهم قولا
معروفا
وليخشى الذين لو تركوا من خلفهم ذريه
ضعافا خافوا عليهم فليتقوا الله وليقولوا
قولا سديدا
ان الذين ياكلون اموال اليتامى ظلما
انما ياكلون في بطونهم نارا وسيصلون سعيرا
يوصيكم الله في اولادكم للذكر مثل حظ
الانثيين
فان كن نساء
فوق اثنتين فلهن ثلثا ما ترك وان كانت
واحده فلها النصف
ولابويه لكل واحد منهما السدس مما ترك ان
كان له ولد فان لم يكن له ولد وورثه ابواه
فلام
الثلث فان كان له اخوه فلاممه
السدس من بعد وصيه يوصي بها او دين
اباؤكم
وابناء
كم لا تدرون ايهم اقرب لكم نفعا
فريضه من الله
ان الله كان عليما حكيما
ولكم نصف ما ترك ازواجكم ان لم يكن لهن
ولد فان كان لهن ولد فلكم الربع مما تركن
من بعد وصيه يوص صين بها او دين
ولهن الربع مما تركتم ان لم يكن لكم ولد
فان كان لكم ولد فلهن
الثمن مما تركتم من بعد وصيه توصون بها او
دين
وان كان رجل يورث كلاله او امراه وله اخ
او اخت
فلكل واحد منهما السدس فان كانوا اكثر من
ذلك فهم شركاء
في الثلث من بعد وصيه يوصى بها او دين غير
مضام
وصيه من الله والله عليم حليم
تلك حدود الله
ومن يطع الله ورسوله يدخله جنات تجري من
تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
وذلك الفوز العظيم
ومن يعصي الله ورسوله ويتعدى حدوده يدخله
نارا خالدا فيها
يدخله نارا خالدا
فيها وله عذاب مهين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال الين
امين
واللاتي ياتين الفاحشه من نسائكم
فاستشهدوا عليهن اربعه منكم فان شهدوا
فامسكوهن
في البيوت حتى يتوفاهن
الموت او يجعل الله لهن سبيلا
والذان ياتيانها منكم فاذوهما
فان تابا واصلحا فاعرضوا عنهما ان الله
كان توابا رحيما
انما التوبه على الله للذين يعملون السوء
بجهاله ثم يتوبون من قريب
فاولئك يتوب الله عليهم وكان الله عليما
حكيما
وليست التوبه للذين يعملون السيئات حتى
اذا حضر احدهم الموت قال اني تبت الان ولا
الذين يموتون وهم كفار
اولئك
اعتدنا لهم عذابا اليما
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يحل لكم ان ترثوا
النساء كرها ولا تعضلوهن لتذهبوا ببعض ما
اتيتموهن
الا ان ياتين بفاحشه مبينه
وعاشروهن
بالمعروف
فان كرهتموهن
فعسى ان تكرهوا شيئا ويجعل الله فيه خيرا
كثيرا
وان اردتم استبدال زوج مكان زوج واتيتم
احداهن قنطارا فلا تاخذوا منه شيئا
اتاخذونه بهتانا واثما مبينا
وكيف تاخذونه وقد افضى بعضكم الى بعض واخذ
منكم ميثاقا غليظا
ولا تنكحوا ما نكح اباؤكم
من النساء الا ما قد سلف انه كان فاحشه
ومقتا وساء سبيلا
حرمت عليكم امهاتكم وبناتكم واخواتكم
وعماتكم
وخالاتكم وبنات الاخ وبنات الاخت وامهاتكم
التي ارضعنكم
وامهاتكم
التي ارضعنكم واخواتكم
من الرضاعه
وامهات نسائكم
وربائبكم
التي في حجولكم من نسائكم
التي دخلتم بهن
فان لم تكونوا دخلتم بهن فلا جناح عليكم
وحلائل
ابنائكم
الذين من اصلاكم وان تجمعوا بين الاختين
الا ما قد سلف ان الله كان غفورا رحيما
والمحصنات من النساء
الا ما ملكت ايمانكم كتاب الله عليكم واحل
لكم ما وراء ذلكم ان تبتغوا باموالكم
محصنين غير مسافحين
فما استمتعتم به منهن فاتوهن
اجورهن فريضه
ولا جناح عليكم فيما تراضيتم به من بعد
الفريضه
ان الله كان عليما حكيما
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
الشافع والوتر صلاه والشفع والوتر
الله اكبر
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
الضالين
امين
والضحى والليل اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك وما
قلى ولا الاخره خير لك من الاولى ولسوف
يعطيك ربك فترضى الم يجدك يتيما
فاوى ووجدك ضالا
فهدى ووجدك عائلا
فاغنى فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر واما السائل
فلا تنهر واما بنعمه ربك فحدث
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
[Arabic recitation]
ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله افواجا
فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره انه كان توابا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا
فيه ملء السماء السماوات وملء الارض وملء
ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل الثناء والمجد احق
ما قال العبد وكلنا لك عبد الله مانع لما
اعطيت ولا معطي لما منعت ولا ينفع ذا الجد
منك الجد اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا
فيمن عافيت وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك اللهم لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك سبحانك تقضي
بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
نستغفرك اللهم من كل ذنب وخطيئه ونتوب
اليك ونؤمن بك ونتوكل عليك ونكل اليك
الامر كله
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقواتنا ابدا ما ابقيتنا واجعله
الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا
وانصرنا على من عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا
في ديننا ولا تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا
مبلغ علمنا ولا تجعل الى النار مصيرنا
واجعل اللهم
الجنه دارنا وقرارنا
برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا كلها دقها وجلها اولها واخرها
علاتها وسرها ما علمنا منها وما لم نعلم
برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين رب اغفر وارحم
واعف وتكرم وتجاوز عما تعلم
انك تعلم ما لا نعلم انك انت الله الاعز
الاكرم
اللهم انا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو امائك
نواصينا بيدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل فينا
قضاؤك نسالك اللهم بكل اسم هو لك سميت به
نفسك او انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من
خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك ان
تجعل القران العظيم ربيع قلوبنا ونور
صدورنا وذهاب همومنا وجلاء غمومنا
واحزاننا
اللهم علمنا منه ما جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما
نسينا وارزقنا تلاوته والعمل به اناء
الليل واطراف النهار
على الوجه الذي يرضيك عنا برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين. اللهم اجعلنا ممن يقيمون حروفه
وحدوده ولا تجعلنا ممن يضيعون حروفه
وحدوده. اللهم اجعلنا من اهل القران الذين
هم اهلك وخاصتك
برحمتك يا رب العالمين. سبحان ربك رب
العزه عما يصفون وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين وصل اللهم وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
والتابعين
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
بصان يعني الحمد لله السلام عليكم
قراءه مميز الليله ما شاء الله
شويه والله
[Arabic recitation]